eigentlich bilden kristalle regelmäßige
strukturen im raum jetzt haben zwei
forschungsgruppen aber kristalle
erschaffen die regelmäßige strukturen in
der zeit haben
das ist ziemlich verrückt und ein neuer
aggregatzustand gebildet wird er durch
regelmäßige gitter doch diese verändern
ihrem zustand in regelmäßigen takt das
klingt sehr nach science fiction und
galt in der theorie tatsächlich lange
als unmöglich welche anwendungen könnten
uns also dieser neuer materiezustand
ermöglichen und machen diese zeit
kristalle bald sogar zeitreisen möglich
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
messenger gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
alle wichtigen facts zum thema herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction
übrigens haben wir jetzt auch den
facebook messenger instagram und
telegramm als messenger hinzugefügt also
noch mehr möglichkeiten dabei zu sein
alle infos gibt es am ende des videos
2012 hatte der amerikanische
nobelpreisträger frank wilczek ein
theoretisches modell aufgestellt in dem
es um die existenz sogenannter zeit
kristalle ging ihr wisst es vielleicht
charakteristisch für kristalle sich
beispielsweise diamanten ist dass ihre
atome in regelmäßigen dreidimensionalen
gitterstrukturen angeordnet sind sie
bilden quasi die grund einheiten der
kristalle die sich im raum wiederholt
bei zeit christan ist dies anders bei
ihnen existieren solche sich
wiederholenden diskreten zustände im
bezug auf die zeit ihre bausteine ändern
also periodisch ihren zustand und das
ist wirklich ganz besonders stellt euch
mal vor ihr bewegt euch durch einen
herkömmlichen kristall in immer gleichen
abständen trifft man auf ein atom oder
molekül auch bei zeit kristallen ist die
struktur wieder kennt aber eben in der
zeit um im bild zu bleiben hier würde
man sich nicht durch den raum bewegen
sondern an einer stelle verharren und
waren dabei würde man beobachten dass
sich die umgebung ständig ändert bis sie
dann nach einer bestimmten zeitspanne
wieder genauso aussieht wie am anfang
selbst nachdem das theoretische modell
des amerikanischen forscher
veröffentlicht wurde galt was bei vielen
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftlern
als komplett unmöglich doch jetzt
existiert nicht nur mehr dieses
theoretische modell zwei forschungsteams
von den
in harvard und princeton haben solche
zeit kristalle jetzt tatsächlich in die
realität umgesetzt und das auf
unterschiedliche art und weise das
besondere bei beiden sie pulsieren im
prinzip ohne energiezufuhr vor sich her
und das scheint zunächst einmal den
gesetzen der physik zu widersprechen der
ist jetzt zeit kristall besteht aus zehn
etablierte millionen in die in einem
elektrischen feld schwebt laserpulse von
außen lassen die spins also quasi die
einen eigenen drehimpuls der teilchen
umklappen und verhindern so dass das
system ins gleichgewicht kommt an dieser
stelle könnte man denken dass die ionen
dem takt des lesers folgen aber genau
das gegenteil war der fall
die ep um ihnen bildeten eigene
wechselwirkungen aus und klappt nur bei
jedem zweiten laserpuls um nach ansicht
des forschungsteams bestätigt diese
beobachtung dass das system eine
eigenständige und zeitlich diskretes
struktur eingenommen hat ein zeit
kristall also der zweite erschaffene
zeit christa von der harvard university
besteht aus einem synthetischen
diamanten in seinem kohlenstoff gitter
sind eine million fehlstellen an diesen
sogenannten stickstoff lücken lagert
sich statt dem kohlenstoffatom 1
stickstoff atom an
mit hilfe von mikrowellen gelang es dem
forschungsteam das in diesen lücken
spins umgeklappt wurden doch auch hier
entstand ein tag der doppelt so langsam
war wie das wechseln muster des pins und
so heißt es in der studie zitat dieses
system bricht damit die zugrundeliegende
zeitliche symmetrie des pulses und
bildet die diskrete ordnung eines zeit
rist als beide experimente scheinen also
tatsächlich zu belegen dass zeit
kristalle existieren selbst wenn sie so
lange als unmöglichkeiten doch was
bedeutet dieser neue materiezustand für
unsere zukunft dazu eine der beteiligten
forscherinnen des harvard teams medica
khemani mit der schaffung der zeit
kristalle haben wir eine neue
materiezustand geschaffen und so den
katalog der möglichen ordnung in raum
und zeit um einen eintrag erweitert
beispielsweise könnten daten in
quantencomputer besser gegen störungen
abgesichert werden denn laser
manipulierte ionenfallen
in der diamanten werden als bauteile in
quantencomputern eingesetzt zudem könnte
man mit zeit kristallen extrem schwache
magnetfelder und niedrige temperaturen
einfacher messen doch selbst zu diesen
ideen da steckt die forschung noch in
den kinderschuhen und auch zeitreisen ja
werden durch diesen neuen
aggregatzustand nicht möglich werden
schade wenn er als erstes neues dazu und
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer hier im
messenger und das geht jetzt nicht nur
bei uns sondern instagram facebook und
telegramm sind auch dabei und dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
ihr könnt doch direkt über mich in der
redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und
mitbestimmen was hierbei clixoom
passiert und jetzt eben haben wir neben
mord auch ins tram face book und den
telekom messenger dabei und zur
begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines
geschenk einfach hier draufklicken
natürlich nicht das abo mit der genauen
blogger vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken die genaueste und der welt
ansonsten will ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran